momento para la información económica en
france 24 me acompañen del estudio
nuestra compañera mila blandón y vamos a
comenzar hablando de eeuu porque
millones de personas se podrían quedar
sin esas ayudas para el desempleo así es
wang pues el próximo lunes de cuento que
van a expirar dos programas de ayudas
semanales extra al desempleo en ese país
uno que ayuda a los trabajadores
autónomos y otro que otorga 300 dólares
semanales adicionales a los desempleados
como resultado unos 10 millones de
personas perderían esos pagos federales
de acuerdo con una estimación de oxford
economics aunque seguirán recibiendo
beneficios estatales estas ayudas
nacieron durante la pandemia para ayudar
a quienes perdieron su trabajo valga la
redundancia pero han sido muy criticados
sobre todo por los republicanos porque
han desincentivado a las personas a
volver a sus puestos de hecho el número
de vacantes esto es muy sorprendente
juanes está registrando recortar mes a
mes y llaman unos 10 millones pasamos a
hablar de noticias de américa latina
porque los diputados brasileños
aprobaron una pequeña reforma tributaria
sí señora el proyecto que cuenta con la
aprobación del presidente ya ir
bolsonaro tiene como principal cambio de
fondo un gravamen del 15 por ciento de
las ganancias por dividendos que están
exentas en el país desde en
1995 la iniciativa también prevé que los
impuestos que las empresas pagan sobre
sus rentas bajen del actual 15 por
ciento al 8% en cuanto a los
trabajadores eleva a 2.500 reales o unos
500 dólares el salario mínimo sujeto al
impuesto de renta que hasta hoy es de
1900 reales o lo equivalente a 380
dólares ahora el proyecto es hoy
remitido al senado que aparte está
discutiendo otra reforma tributaria de
mucho mayor alcance y de la que
hablaremos en su momento pero ahora sí
vamos a el salvador porque en este país
hay protestas por el bitcoin si en el
principal mercado artesanal de la
capital del salvador los comerciantes
protagonizaron una protesta a menos de
una semana de que el bitcoin se
convierta en moneda de curso legal ellos
denuncian que ningún funcionario ayuda a
explicarles cómo funcionará
beneficios puede traerles su
implementación de todas maneras sobre
este tema las posiciones son bastante
encontradas escuchamos a el pueblo no la
quiere además de la inestabilidad que
representa la moneda no hay una fijación
de precios entonces golpearía
a los sectores populares como es posible
que diga que para ser va a ser optativa
en el uso de la moneda cuando la cuando
la ley dice que va a ser de curso legal
eso quiere decir que nos guste o no nos
guste vamos a tener que usar ya listo no
creemos en los cambios no nos gustan los
cambios pero si en realidad comprendemos
que eso nada más es algo que nos va a
venir a agilizar
la economía a ser más fácil a incluir a
personas que la banca excluye yo creo
que cuando ya estamos en ese punto vamos
a decir
y por esto nos estamos quejando
una noticia que seguro va a tener
muchísima repercusión vamos a asia
porque tenemos que hablar de sindicatos
en china porque porque mira firmas como
dee dee jay dee puntocom han estado en
la mira de las autoridades en medio de
una agresiva campaña contra los titanes
tecnológicos en múltiples frentes
incluidos los juegos la computación en
la nube entre otros y todos van por el
tema laboral beijing se ha comprometido
a hacer que las empresas compartan su
riqueza con los empleados y en el caso
del transporte les dio un plazo a estas
dos empresas para hasta terminar este
año para corregir las tácticas de
mercado injustas que afectan tanto a la
competencia como a los trabajadores ya
que estas compañías a menudo compiten
ofreciendo descuentos e incentivos a los
pasajeros para el gobierno chino de
estos empleados están siendo explotados
pues trabajan largas horas y sin
prestaciones sociales básicas momento de
hablar de los indicadores económicos de
este día 2 de septiembre wall street'
del cerro en positivo y de nuevo sus
principales índices standard and poor's
y el tecnológico nasdaq marcaron récords
ayudados por muy buenas cifras de empleo
en estados
es una situación que también alentó a
las bolsas europeas hablamos
concretamente de las solicitudes de
subsidio por desempleo que bajaron en la
última semana a
340.000 y finalmente en américa latina'
la reforma aprobada en brasil hizo caer
la bolsa de sao paulo en más del 2%
cifra del día 18 mil 400 millones de
dólares es el proyecto de presupuesto
nacional para 2022 presentado por el
gobierno de costa rica 1,94 por ciento
mayor al del año pasado
daré muchísimas gracias y gracias
también ustedes quédense en france 24
[Música]